hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well prudence in greed
for Mesa so sometimes translated as
practical wisdom it is one of the five
intellectual virtues the the mental
dispositions that that are developed as
as habits as lasting structures within
the human mind or the human soul that
Aristotle discusses in in his treatment
of them in Nicomachean ethics book six
you'll notice that Aristotle devotes
more attention to prudence than he does
to any of the other intellectual virtues
and this makes good sense because it is
a book that's focused on ethics and
prudence as it's going to turn out it is
not just something valuable for its own
sake the way that say wisdom is it is
also absolutely central in Aristotle's
conception of ethics and of the good
person so it shares some scope with
another one of the intellectual virtues
that is technical art or craft or skill
bond it's much more centrally focused on
things that are manners as he says I do
praxis rather than just a production how
do we behave you might say prudence is
concerned with how we prioritize how do
we figure things out in in our wider
life what kind of lifestyle we prefer
all of these are manners for for
Prudential thinking so he says that it
involves deliberating places and
deliberating well not poorly arriving at
truth truth in action practical truths
right about what is good or useful on
his own covers a wide range of good the
useful the some Pharaon is one kind of
good but we can also talk about the
noble the cologne we can talk about the
just or the right dick I own we could
talk about the pleasurable and the
prudent person deliberate swell about
this entire range of moral values
goodness justice pleasure usefulness
appropriateness we could add all sorts
of other things in and the things that
they apply to and how like it but here
how they figure in for oneself what is
good for oneself what is useful for
oneself even as Aristotle goes on to say
the prudent person is not just prudent
in one aspect of their life for example
we might think of a business person who
really manages their business well but
then there what we call a hot mess once
they they get out of their business
perhaps even after they close think
about about business owners who are
great while they're on and then after
they close they sit there behind the bar
and drink with their employees and get
snookered and and you know run into all
sorts of problems as a result some other
people are good at managing their their
personal life but not very good in their
career other people are good at
they're family relationships but have
trouble with friends we could go on and
on and on
this applies particularly well to
students who often have a difficult time
transitioning from student life where
they had mastered a bunch of skills it
might involve prudence in a limited way
thinking about what do I need to do to
get through this semester how can i you
know what sort of internships that you
and then they get out of that they're
they're at a loss so it's it's in terms
not just of one area of one's life but
one's entire life the whole as Aristotle
says meaning the entirety not just the
length of one's life duration but you
might say all of the aspects all of the
dimensions of one's life a little bit
later because this starts to sound as if
the prudent person is just concerned
with him or herself he will he will say
that it is a true rational habit right
so it's a it's a cabinet axis it's true
holidays meaning that it's a truth
attaining property all of the
intellectual virtues are about concerned
with attaining truth and this is truth
in action which means truth in what one
does and also with what my desires and
what one chooses and in case it's a
truth true rational habit concerned with
action practicals in Greek bearing upon
what our self says what is good or bad
and there he just uses the generic terms
I got Agatha and khakha meaning good or
bad in all the different varieties for
human being as such the term there is
actually the singular but when he uses
apropos he doesn't usually just mean an
individual human being he means human
beings human being and a little bit
later when he talks about Heracles he
brings the two of these together he says
that what we consider a prudent person
is somebody who deliberate as well not
just for themselves and there it's
actually the plural for themselves but
also for people in
people in their society the people that
they're charged with so it's kind of
it's got a double side to it it's about
you know how I take care of my own life
but also it involves being able to
deliberate well about the human good in
general and about other human beings so
for example who might be an example you
know somebody who would apply this well
if you think about what what advising or
coaching involves if you really do have
a prudent advisor they are a person who
can deliberate well and not only in
their own case but in your case about
the things that matter to you and about
what will turn out well or what will
turn out badly what you want to do so he
says them to involve some skill in and
reasoning interestingly the terms here
are he talks about a person who's being
stochastic Oh Scott
total oh nice alone this by the way is
the word that we get stochastic scrum
which which you know it has to do with
being able to predict how it comes what
we small means reasoning practical
reasoning in this case the part of the
soul that this intellectual virtue is
seeded with that is the low beast mode
part of the salt the part that engages
in thinking things out in weighing
alternatives
he had say well if I do this then what
are the consequences or what are the
possible outcomes for that so it does
involve some some practical reasoning
processes which may be explicit may be
implicit he says it also does involve
some understanding of general principles
the universals the things that apply
across the board but this is very
important it descends to the level of
particulars as he says in in this
passage here was in Chapter seven it
must take account of a particular fact
since it's concerned with act
and action deals with particular things
this is why and this great point here
people who are ignorant of general
principles or something's more
successful in action than others who
know that for example here's one from
from medicine Aristotle himself came
from a medical family a man who knows
that light meat is easily digested in
therefore a wholesome but does not know
what kinds of meat in a light that
person will not be so likely to restore
you to health as a man merely knows that
chicken is wholesome in other manners of
experience the other management of
experience are more successful than the
theorists and so Aristotle says it's
needed to have some background with the
particulars he thinks that some of this
comes from that other intellectual
virtue which we call intellect or
intelligence or understanding news that
is concerned with particulars in
practical matters we also derive our
understanding of particulars from as he
says a stasis or or perception sense
perception we perceive what is going on
in a situation but prudence has to bring
it all together and help the person
understand what is actually good or bad
in the situation I don't actually have
this up on the board but it goes along
with deliberation what is deliberation
concerned with the liberation is
concerned with how we get from how we
get to ends that we desire what meanings
we need to select prudence is a kind of
excellence in selecting the appropriate
means to get from point A to point B so
for example if we want to actually be
happy prudence is necessary in order for
us to select the right means for
happiness it may in fact be involved
even in our conception of happiness he
also discusses how prudence might be
seen as something different they
but it actually does encompass when it's
understood in its broad sense other
other types of skills or we call the
mental mental habit is's hexes household
management wait gonna McKay this is the
word that we get economics from if you
would actually have any sort of
resources you have to manage those and
that often means not only managing those
resources but managing your relationship
with everybody else in your household
and how they're you know bringing in and
expending in your relation with
everybody outside of the household that
you have some sort of relations with the
whole field of politics by this he means
you know we're we're deliberating that
well what want me to do is should we go
to war should we raise tariffs or not
should we sentence this person
legislation also fits in with that these
are all things that the Greeks were
quite familiar with and and concerned
with in our own time you might have in
things like organizational behavior
being a matter for prudence in many
respects there are certain principles
you can get textbooks and study
organizational behavior but the the
leaders of organizations who are
actually successful and created good
organizational culture they don't do it
just according to the textbook as a
matter of fact the textbooks are often
written afterwards trying to make sense
Hut what these people did that was
successful quite often technocratic
leaders tend to alienate people and
produce cultures that are not
particularly successful and let alone
cohesive and good places to work a
Prudential a frenetic manager will
understand you know we need the goods
that are at play in a given situation
against each other and there are no hard
and fast rules for how to do this that
apply
in every case from Asus is that habit
that that intellectual virtue that
supplies us with you know not only it
coordinates the reasoning process from
the particulars taking all those into
account and the general principles the
means to the end it also helps to guide
that entire process as well and so you
know if we could reduce it to a science
somebody would get up by now but if it
can't be this is a absolutely central in
Aristotle's conception of ethics in
order to live the good life in order to
be oriented well towards the good life a
person is going to have to cultivate
some degree of for an ASUS